so a liquidity crisis is when you have a
lot of financial institutions that are
in good shape but they're just kind of
short of cash and they need somebody
like the Federal Reserve to tide them
over until they can get back on their
feet and but they basically have made
good loans the solvency crisis is when
the loans that a bank has made are so
lousy that even if it could collect them
all on the day of the of the crisis they
wouldn't get enough money to pay off
their depositors clearly this crisis
began as a liquidity crisis and that's
how the Fed treated it but eventually
became a solvency crisis and that's why
in the end the federal government put a
lot of taxpayer capital into the banks
that's how you rebuild the foundations
the problem is that it's not always
clear when you're crossing a line from
liquidity to solvency and it's certainly
not always clear at the moment you have
to make a judgment
agree with the premise I mean the reason
that Bernanke joined Paulson and going
to Congress to ask for seven hundred
billion dollars of taxpayer money was
that he knew it was a solvency crisis
the reason lehman brothers went down was
not liquidity with solvency so i think
there was a political tactic decision
about at what point do you go to the
ramparts and shout we need taxpayer
money the banks are bust and how do you
do that so you get the money but you
don't frighten people into all cowering
under their dining room tables but I
don't think there was a problem of
analysis here now I do think there's a
problem of sometimes the people in the
room look at their clients as the
financial institutions and that's
particularly true of people who have
spent their life in the financial
industry Hank Paulson at the Treasury
Bernanke has tried to explain this when
he went on 60 minutes he said I did not
set out to save Wall Street I set out to
save main street in order to save Main
Street I had to save Wall Street I think
that's a coherent view he believes that
finance is crucial to the well
functioning of the economy where most of
us live and work but it turns out to be
such a complicated sentence that most
Americans can't follow
this is one that really requires like
hitting the rewind button and then
changing the plot and then hitting the
fast-forward button and see what the
ending is it's kind of an impossible
question to answer surely it would have
been better if somebody in the
government was charged with having an
overarching responsibility for the
stability of the financial system and
had both the mandate and the capacity to
say you know there's just an awful lot
of bad mortgage loans being made and we
should make less than or to say that
securitization turning loans into
securities is causing problems because
the people who make the loans just pass
the hot potato to the security holder
who buys them and they don't have any
skin in the game so as a result they
making a lot of lousy loans so surely
that would have made a difference I
don't think that the stuff about Fed
transparency the Fed providing more
information really would have made much
difference before the crisis most of
what people are upset about is not what
happened before the crisis but the
lending that the Fed did during the
crisis and so I think that's an issue
and I think that also having a system
where there are so many bank regulators
and there's so much turf battle going on
was clearly not helpful and it's
unfortunate that it doesn't look like
the pending legislation will consolidate
that frame the government could have
been much clearer about what it was
doing there was a lot of confusion about
what the Paulson Bernanke Geithner
program was I think that you can never
set out a perfect set of principles that
say this is how will respond in this
circumstance but they should have done
more of that would have been better if
the government had more authority going
into the crisis to deal with the
collapse of a financial institution
other than a bank so that they would
have had a choice in September 2008 that
was better than bankruptcy Lehman
Brothers or bail out AIG it would be
better if there were some fund that the
Treasury secretary and the Fed Chairman
and the head of the FDIC could tap in an
emergency that didn't require going to
Congress something that had maybe a lot
of locks on it but at least somebody
would have the key so that the
government could fire back
the country was attacked by a financial
virus instead of twiddling its thumbs
and doing all these jury-rigged programs
until Congress got around to giving them
the money so I think those are a few
things
I think this is a question that we don't
yet know enough to answer but clearly
they did not impose a haircut on the
counterparties to AIG clearly those
counterparties the big banks Goldman
Sachs Deutsche Bank the rest of them had
a strong interest in the system and it
would have been I would like to have
known I would like to know just how hard
did the Fed try to tell him look
everybody's got to take 98 cents on the
dollar or eighty-seven cents on the
dollar we're not bailing anybody at one
hundred percent but there were a lot of
problems one was this was a
international company and it's one thing
for the Fed and the Treasury to lean on
JP Morgan and Goldman Sachs and Morgan
Stanley the French banks might be a lot
less susceptible to the charms of Ben
Bernanke and hank paulson and you could
have a really bad international dispute
over this but most importantly this was
happening with a lot of other things
going on it was kind of a busy week
there first they marry bank of america a
merry bank of america and merrill lynch
then they have this problem with Lehman
Brothers and then right behind late
early hours later they're dealing with
AIG so I don't think you can look at any
one of these things in isolation sure if
they had six months to think about it
they probably would have done a better
job in retrospect should they have done
something more to force a credit haircut
on the counterparties of AIG I think the
answer to that is yes could they have
done it with the power they had in the
circumstances they were confronting I
honestly don't know
I don't because I don't think that you
can have full employment and price
stability and ignore the financial
system and ignore asset bubbles my gosh
if there's anything we've learned in the
last five years is that employment has a
lot to do with what goes on in asset
bubbles we have 10.2 percent
unemployment today and it's not because
of conventional monetary policy raising
interest rates because there was an
increase in the Consumer Price Index
it's the result of a finance bubble so I
don't think the Fed can do its job
without looking at that stuff that
doesn't mean that the Fed has to have
the authority to supervise every bank in
America and there's an honest debate
that goes on among people many of them
allies of the Fed about whether the Fed
should or shouldn't have that direct
authority but I don't think acid bubbles
are a distraction I think acid bubbles
are a key part of their mission
well Ben Bernanke has a really hard task
now he has to decide when is the right
moment to contract credit and raise
interest rates if he does it too soon
we'll get a relapse into recession
that's what happened in 1937 when the
depression was extended because the Fed
was too tight at the wrong time on the
other hand if he waits too long we'll
get an outbreak of inflation greater
than he thinks is prudent so I don't
think anybody thinks the moment is to
tighten is today the argument is over
how soon should the Fed do that some of
that depends on how the economy performs
and I think that it's a tricky balance
it takes a great deal of technical skill
this is not like any recession we've
seen in our lifetime and that means that
we can't be sure the economy is going to
react in the same ways it takes a great
deal of luck because you just got to get
it right and sometimes you'd have to
make a guess you don't have the luxury
of waiting for to see how the play is
going to end before you decide what role
you going to play in the third act and
finally it's going to take a lot of
political courage on Bernanke's part the
Fed is under attack by the public by the
Congress and he is undoubtedly going to
have to raise interest rates and drain
credit to the system before everybody
thinks the economy's back to normal and
he's going to have to do that at a
moment when the Congress is looking at
the powers of the Fed and the law that
governs it and so it's not going to be
popular and it's going to be tricky and
so we all can only hope that he has the
technical skill the lock and the
political guts to do it at the right
time because if he does it the wrong
time we'll have a much worse economy
than if he does it at the right time
his first constituency is his own
colleagues at the Fed I think he's got
them pretty much in line although there
are some people who are outspokenly
critical of him inside the fed the
second constituencies the American
people because Congress is hostile to
the fed because they sense that the
people are hostile the gallup poll did a
survey in the summer of 2009 and they
found that fewer people think the Fed is
doing good jobs than any other federal
agency that they mentioned including the
IRS the Fed has become a lightning rod
for all the anger about the sense that
Wall Street got bailed out and Main
Street didn't he like Greenspan and like
Volcker before him the Congress is an
important constituency for the Fed and
its chairman that I called the Fed the
fourth branch of government in the
subtitle of my book and that's a way to
express just how much clout and
independence they had during this crisis
but the fact is it's not enshrined in
the Constitution and Congress could
change the law and it could change the
law in ways that would make it harder
for the Fed to do its job particularly
harder to raise interest rates or lower
than what I think it's appropriate so
that means courting a lot of members of
Congress not only the powerful ones like
barney frank and chris dodd the chairman
of the two relevant committees in the
house and senate but also the
rank-and-file members who have to vote
on things and a lot of them think the
Fed is a bunch of bank protecting knit
wits and they're hostile and then
finally they do have a constituency on
Wall Street in markets we in this
country rely on the willingness of lots
of people with money around the world to
lend it to us at very cheap rates that's
the only reason why we could have this
big stimulus package it's the only
reason why the federal government could
be running such a big deficit and to
some extent Ben Bernanke and his
colleagues of the Fed or the custodians
of the US dollar and if people think
we're going to have a lot of inflation
here or a lot of bank failures or a lot
of other problems they're not going to
be willing to hold so many dollar
that means they will have to pay more to
borrow so he can't ignore the markets
but they are not his only constituency